the debate is over one of the best
mousing keyboard players in Apex Legends
just won a championship using a
controller obviously I'm biased but I
feel like I'm probably the only player
that can maybe play as good as they are
on masuki on controller a few months
back TSM Superstar Imperial Hal got so
sick of trying to tell everyone how
overpowered controller aim assist was
that he decided to prove it instead yeah
I controllers you just do everything I
guess huh yes I'll show you
not only did HAL spearhead TSM to a
third international title he was awarded
an MVP trophy for his efforts I I took a
big risk playing controller and swapping
is something that I haven't played in
for a while and it all paid off so this
makes Hal the only player in history to
win titles on two separate inputs say
what you will about aim assist that is
King